uh
thanks everyone
being in this important meeting so thank
you thank you thank you
and governor newsom you're trying to
make us feel bad listen that magnificent
background you have over there
and when i'm sitting in here in the in
the white house
god love you anyway it's good to see you
all really thank you
um for years the president has
received a briefing at the beginning of
the hurricane season
looking at the trends that are coming to
get a sense of what's
coming so that the country can be better
prepared
and when i received that briefing this
year
i asked uh for a second briefing that
uh that does the same thing but now
we're doing about
wildfire season and uh we know
this is uh this is becoming a regular
cycle and we know it's getting worse
in fact the threat of western wildfires
this year is as severe
as it's ever been and i wanted to
convene this group of governors of
western state governors key members of
my cabinet female leadership
and the leadership from utility
industries and senior members of our
white house team
to make sure we're doing everything and
i mean this sincerely we're doing
everything possible to help you prepare
for what's coming
and some is already there the truth is
we're playing catch-up
this is an area that has been
under-resourced
but that's going to change if we have
anything to do with it
we can't cut corners when it comes to
managing our wildfires or supporting our
firefighters
and this briefing is going to be an
annual event to make sure
we're focusing on preventing fires the
fire threats in the first place as well
as responding
when they arise but right now we have to
act
and act fast we're late in the game here
we're remembering the horrific scenes
from last year
orange skies that looked like end of
days smoke and ash that
made the air dangerous to breathe more
than 10 million acres burned
billions of dollars in economic damage
families that lost their homes and
everything they own
and too many too many lost lives
and this year we there could be even
tougher based on the weather patterns
you know california and some other
places the drought conditions are twice
that's what that what they were last
year
and right now we're seeing record heat
in portland and across the west
and this year uh you know 21 large
uncontained fires were burning this year
there are 36
that are uncontained and burning there
are already about
9 000 firefighters deployed across the
region from california to new mexico to
utah and nevada
and it's only june i know i realize i'm
preaching to the choir here i know you
all
know this better than any other people
in the country
the fire season traditionally lasts
through october
but with climate change climate change
is driving the dangerous confluence of
extreme heat and prolonged drought
we're seeing wildfires of greater
intensity that move with more speed
you know and lasts well beyond
traditional months
the traditional months of the fire
season and that's a problem for
all of us wildfires are wildfires are
not a partisan phenomenon
they don't stop at a county or a state
line
or a country line for that matter we
need a coordinated comprehensive
response with all the federal working
all the federal government working in
close cooperation
to support you the states that's what
this is about we want to know what you
the states and localities and tribal
governments
and those in the front lines are facing
in this danger and what you think would
help the most
today we're taking critical steps to
help protect american communities
right away first we're going to make
sure that we have
enough firefighters on call who are
trained equipped and ready to respond
for all this fire season and we're and
we're going to pay them they i mean the
idea
these folks are running into anyway we
should pay them
last week i learned that some of our
federal firefighters are being paid less
than 13
an hour come on man this is that's
unacceptable to me
and i'm meeting the director of my team
to take decisive action to fix it
so today we're announcing what i still
think is not enough
this year we're going to provide a
retention incentives that's going to
ensure federal
wet wildland fires our firefighters are
making at least 15
an hour provide for additional 10
bonuses for those working on the front
lines
but a one-time boost is not enough
these courageous women and men take an
incredible risk of running toward the
fire
and they deserve to be paid and paid
good wages you know that old expression
god made man then he made a few
firefighters well it's true
they're incredible i've spent a lot of
time my whole career with them
so so we're going to work with congress
i know many of
your senators and representatives have
been working hard on this
for to permanently get federal
firefighters a better deal including
improvements in their compensation
their benefits and their work life
balance
the federal government is also offering
funding when governor is requested
to train and equip national guard
members so they have a
they're ready to provide a surge of
firefighting capacity
you know one of the things we i learned
over the years being so deeply involved
with the firefighters the only thing
that saves a firefighter's life is
another firefighter
that's the single most consequential
thing and you know
one of the hardest speeches i've ever
had to make and you've all we've all
made
difficult speeches was at the funeral
of the 19 granite mountain hotshot
firefighters
when the prescott arizona fire
department got clobbered
that tragedy happened eight years ago
today that's the reason i mentioned it
it's hard to remember of all the costs
that firefighters risk when they do
their job
and their bravery to step up and do the
job
now traditionally federal firefighting
has been a seasonal job
but because the climate change and i
know you all know it i hope your
constituents know it there is
climate change it's no longer a seasonal
job
this is a year-round mission so we've
made sure
seasonal firefighters can stay on the
job as long as they are needed this year
by allowing them to work beyond their
term
and for next year we're working to make
more than of those positions permanent
positions
so so that when fires aren't burning
we have a workforce of experienced hands
enhancing our forest management
reducing the risk of future fire in the
future fire season
second thing we are harnessing new tools
and technologies to better identify and
respond before new fires grow
into large uncontrolled conflagrations
so for example
the national ocean the the national
ocean gra
ocean ocean of oceanic and atmospheric
administration noaa
has satellite technology that is able to
see from space
when new fires start while they are
still small
even as small as the size of your dining
room table
similarly the department of energy has a
sensor array computer analysis
capability that can detect
in real time the lightning strikes that
might set
off a blaze and we're going to use those
tools to identify
fires that start in remote places and
share that information so the
firefighters on the ground can respond
immediately
before fires spread out of control i
know that's not a full answer but it's
real it will improve things
we're also going to make sure that the
people have the information
to better protect themselves and their
families from smoke and fire risks
this will include launching a new app a
new app on
and from epa so individuals can easily
access the latest information on air
quality
smoke plumes and public health guidance
third we also have to make investments
in our future
that's why the bipartisan infrastructure
framework investment
of about 50 billion dollars in the in
the by so-called
anyway i won't go into but a bill that's
caused a little
attention um infrastructure bill is
going to bill re
build resilience to extreme weather
events like wildfires 50 billion dollars
and today i'm announcing a 37 million
dollar federal grant to sonoma county
california
in support of fire mitigation efforts
that are underway
this grant is part of fema's brick
program building resilient
infrastructure and communities
my administration doubled brick funding
to support local efforts to strengthen
the resilience
and because sonoma knows all too well
the devastation wrought by fires
they were the first to apply for the
mitigation funding i encourage more
communities to do so next year
and finally i want to note that the
extreme heat we're seeing in the west is
not only a risk
amplifier for wildfires it's a threat in
and of itself
people are hurting it's more dangerous
for kids to play outside
roads are buckling under the heat i mean
that again need not tell all of you
we need people to check on their
neighbors especially seniors who may
need a helping hand
outdoor laborers like our former
construction workers are going to need
frequent water breaks
and shade i want to thank the governors
and
local leaders for providing information
to citizens and the resources like
cooling centers where people can go to
get relief from the heat
and to our utility leaders we are ready
to work with you
to make sure that people have access to
power including air conditioning
under these extreme demand conditions
while continuing to advance our climate
goals
now i'm eager to hear from each of you
each of the governors as to what
experience has been
in your state and what we can do better
to be helpful
because this is an area where investing
and prevention and preparation today
you can deliver invaluable returns
tomorrow and the federal government is
going to have to do
have your backs and that's going to
that's my intention
i'll close by just saying thank you
to everyone from the forest service to
the department of interior and
agriculture to fema
state local and tribal partners and most
importantly our firefighters
for all your incredible work we've asked
so much of the firefighters already
and i know you're going to continue to
step up i'm going to ask the vice
president harris to say a few words and
then we'll move on
madam vice president thank you mr
president um
first i just want to thank the president
for prioritizing this
for his administration um
this is a personal issue for me as a
daughter of california and i say hello
to my
governor gavin newsom i grew up with
drought warnings my brother-in-law
is a california firefighter
as a senator i have visited the scene
while the embers were still smoldering
of the fires paradise for example
california
and when i arrived there a whole
community had been wiped out by the fire
the families still
hadn't been let back in but the only
thing standing in that community were
the chimneys
which looked in that scene like
tombstones
the firefighters that were there pointed
out to me
if you look at the driveway i mean it
may be a tragic situation if the cars
are still in the driveway
because that means the folks didn't get
out in time
uh we have so much work to do on this
uh my my home our family home was under
an evacuation order in los angeles so
i've been in that
experience of also saying look the
most things we can grab that are the
most valuable are family photographs
everything else doesn't matter so when i
think about the challenges that we face
as a nation
i know they are real i also know that
we're in a different climate as the
president said on every level
than we were even 10 years ago and
there's a lot of work to do
and part of the leadership of this
administration has been to also
recognize that the federal government's
role
in this regard has to be more than just
putting out fires
it needs to be obviously supporting our
firefighters especially at the federal
level who are not getting paid enough
but it's also about investing in
resilience it's about
investing in adaptation diversifying
water policy in a way we are thinking
about the storage of water both above
ground and underground we're thinking
about recycling and all that we know is
available to us
to actually be smarter in terms of the
conservation of this
diminishing and valuable resource called
water
so i want to thank everyone for your
leadership
because you all are giving people a
sense of confidence while you are trying
to
bring limited resources to what needs to
be addressed in this growing threat
of these wildfires um and the
the bottom line is that as the president
has said his bipartisan
framework for infrastructure it's going
to address a lot of these challenges
but there is other work to be done and
so i look forward to staying in touch
with all of you
and again thank you for your leadership
well thank you
governor brown um uh
if you'd be willing you could give us an
overview
of uh of what year the challenges are
you western
governors are facing and what you think
we should be doing and can do to help
i the floor is yours
thank you so much mr president and madam
vice president
for having us here for this incredibly
important conversation
as you well know we western governors
our states are truly on the front lines
when it comes to drought fires and our
rapidly changing climate
we were talking earlier before you got
on just this weekend
my state of oregon experienced three
consecutive days of record-breaking high
temperatures
across the willamette valley reaching
upwards of 117 degrees
it is unprecedented and unfortunately
it follows one of the most devastating
wildfire seasons in our state's history
last year we had more than 2 000 fires
that burned over a million acres
entire communities were literally wiped
off the map
in minutes we lost nine lives
more than four thousand homes and nearly
two thousand
other structures as you well know the
impact on our communities and our local
economies
will last for years to come oregonians
have been through a lot in the last 18
months we've had
four federal disaster declarations in my
state
since april of 2020 but what last year's
fire season underscored is that
most often those who can least afford
the impacts
are hurt the most our communities of
color our rural and low income
communities were disproportionately
impacted
our disaster preparedness and recovery
services
must be available to everyone regardless
of the language they speak
the color of their skin their economic
situation
whether they own a home or not or their
immigration
status everyone impacted by a disaster
should be eligible
eligible for fema assistance including
our undocumented families it's
absolutely
the right thing to do our local
communities are increasingly
challenged to respond on their own to
the disasters of the scales
we are seeing we've been preparing for
this year's fire season by investing
millions of dollars
shoring up additional resources and
staffing at our office of emergency
management
so they then can support our local and
our tribal partners
however mr president madam vice
president we still have a number of
concerns
it includes whether there will be
available wildfire
and non-fire federal resources
we know as we're entering this wildfire
season
our eastern counterparts are preparing
for a very difficult hurricane
season and so we may not be able to rely
on
other regions to help out this year and
with that in mind i i do want to say
thank you for approving our cost share
adjustment
related to our 2020 labor day wildfires
at 100
for oregon treating this the same as
coven 19
and the same as what happened in
louisiana for their hurricane recovery
efforts
i would also ask that federal
individual assistance be approved for
disaster mitigation
activities for wildfire just as
fema recently approved for hurricanes
and then finally and i i just have to
say gratefully
our good neighbor authority uh we have
partnered with the federal government
over the years to reduce
wildfire risk on federal lands through
collaborative processes including
prescribed
burns removing dead trees and underbrush
with the recent passage of our state
legislation
we have an opportunity to fund even more
of these good neighbor authority
projects
together it's a win-win-win it creates
jobs creates healthy landscapes and
reduces wildfire risk
and we have the dollars to invest now so
we look forward to partnering for you
with you
and we are incredibly grateful mr
president
for your leadership back over to you
well madam governor i i'm not being
solicited we're grateful for your
leadership
i really mean it and uh one of the
things that
i'd like to ask before we move on is
what what would you be looking for
us to do in the fair at the federal
level
to strengthen this agreement to build
off the lessons that you know the
good neighbor agreement and is there
anything in particular
that is you've learned from last season
that would be add to the needs of this
season
well you mentioned it in your remarks mr
president
making sure we have resources to train
our national guardsmen and women
prior to fire season has been extremely
helpful the last two fire seasons
this should be universal practice
nationwide it's
incredibly helpful we have relied on our
national guard
every step of the way throughout the
pandemic and we certainly rely on them
in support activities and firefighting
the other piece and i see chief
christensen there in terms of the good
neighbor authority
this has been extraordinary in our
ability to put
people back to work in our
timber-dependent rural communities
in our ability to create healthy
landscapes
and our ability to provide timber
for the mills and frankly our ability to
reduce
wildfire risk and so more resources
to collaborate and provide what you
describe as
comprehensive collective efforts to
reduce
wildfire risk would be extremely helpful
well we ought to get not in this moment
but we ought to get
no pun intended deeply in the weeds as
to specifically what
can be done and i'd ask my
appropriate cabinet members to be
working with your people
as to what we can do along those lines
because it seems to be self-evident
that that makes a lot of sense um
and uh but we have a lot of other things
to cover here but
i look to dr sherwood are we
moving shortly if you
uh want to ask any further questions of
governors or we can move with the press
departing and we'll continue our
discussions
the vice president shares any questions
and or any cabinet member if they have
any
questions for the governor i what i'm
interested it's
really a follow-up to what the president
asked uh what with each consecutive
wildfire season and and they are growing
in terms of the
the enormity what are we learning
um and and how can the federal
government
address the challenges and the gaps that
you have seen
with each fire season in terms of the
resources but also the approach
and for example including the public
education piece
um including the piece that is about
encouraging the private sector
where appropriate to be engaged around
resilience
and adaptation on the issue of water
policy
what kind of resources do you need that
are
also preventative as well as reactive to
uh to the wildfires themselves
governor newsom do you want to pick that
one up
yeah i know we'll at first if i just
made a little indulgence
thank you uh i'm gathering meta vice
president mr president
i've been waiting almost uh well four
and a half years to hear a president say
what you just said
uh it's profoundly important uh every
word
you spoke and i mean it we look it goes
without saying in california we were
you know we were engaged in a
relationship with the federal government
vis-a-vis the vice president's
question that was more like you know
sparring partners not working partners
uh so we have an opportunity here to
turn the page on the fingerpointing of
the rhetoric we were debating ranking
policies
literally debating reiki policies
in this country in the last few years
but we
our eyes are wide open by the way i'm
here in your forest our forest
uh federal forest in klamath and
siskiyou county do the largest
wildfires that we've had here to date uh
in
this region we were up here yesterday
thank you mr president i
didn't have to make a call to you to get
the fmag approved yesterday
up here in siskiyou county for the
largest of the wire fires
the lava fire which is a few miles away
from me
uh but look the hots are getting hotter
the drives are getting drier
uh the smashed mouth realities of
climate change are here and they're here
decades ahead of when we had anticipated
so across the board
across the board we have to disabuse
ourselves of the old timelines
in the old frames of engagement i mean
the seriousness of this cannot be
underscored
we had last year a heat dome over the
west coast the united states not just
some other one
we're experiencing north of where i am
and governor brown and inslee
experienced
most acutely but that led to 12 000
lightning strikes in 24 hours and
five of the most destructive wildfires
five of the six largest in our history
concurrently in last year's wildfire
season we were burning up we were
choking them we haven't just
heated them and i should just say this
with due respect to those that don't
believe in
science you got to believe your own damn
eyes observed evidence
you know when when you look at that
thermometer 11719 degrees up north we
were 123
down in palm springs two days ago 111
just 48 hours ago
there's no republican thermometer no
democratic
thermometer these realities are here
with us today so
many vice president across the board we
can't just double
down that's that's old stale rhetoric we
have to have a sense of intentionality
and responsibility to radically
change our vegetation force management
policies our suppression policies our
pre-positioning policies
the strategies we're engaging the
president just laid out on technology
strategies and opportunities to develop
partnerships not only with
with interior and not only with fema but
with the department of defense
uh some of those new satellite
technologies that have been around but
opportunities to engage in new
partnerships with those satellite
technologies the mutual aid system
has been stretched in this country
governor brown how many times i called
you last year for resources
inslee cislac polis oh you're on there
thank you
uh but we're stretched we were calling
folks in australia
we were calling folks in canada we had
the pleasure of having folks
firefighters from israel come
because we were that stressed so mr
president just in closing forgive me for
being long-winded
i just want to say this music to my ears
we got to pay our firefighters betterly
more
because we don't have enough
firefighters period full stop
a bureau of land management same thing
we need to really invest in our human
resources
uh and the infrastructure that you have
been preaching over the course last few
weeks because this is also an incredible
economic opportunity to completely
transform our economy and to get off a
carbon
or at least drive it with a carbon-free
engine and to change the way we produce
and consume energy and so i just want to
applaud you
final words for recognizing not only
this moment of
urgency situationally but the
sustainable mindset to
start thinking anew about how we can
reimagine
the future not go back to the 19th
century but
truly dominate the future and your
infrastructure program
is a big part of that as well these
things are connected
and i just want to say we respect and
appreciate your leadership
and we're just grateful and humbled that
you took the time today to be with all
of us
well look gov this is uh i'm not doing
anybody any favor i just think
if i were sitting in your seat or
governor brown's seat
what i'd be i mean this is this is
urgent and uh one